in this video we present flex cents a
transparent fin input surface that is
capable of reconstructing complex and
continuous deformations without the need
for any external sensing such as cameras
this allows for a variety of paper-like
interactions on mobile devices and high
degrees of freedom inputs 16 transparent
piezoelectric sensors are placed on the
periphery of a pin sheet the surface
affords complex Bend and flex gestures
the main contribution of our work is to
take these 16 sparse measurements and
reconstruct the detailed shape and
deformations performed on the flexible
sheet two new algorithms allow us to
accurately reconstruct the freedy shape
of the sheet in a way that has never
been demonstrated before without
external sensing we use a data-driven
approach where we capture raw sensor
data alongside ground truth free DS shap
data using fiducial markers placed on
the sheet a multi-camera setup and an as
rigid as possible regularizer for
inferring occluded points notice how
this ground truth setup is able to
accurately reconstruct the complex
deformations being performed on the
sheet of paper this is critical to
provide training data for our algorithms
we propose two methods that efficiently
reconstruct the shape of the foil the
first is a simple algorithm based on
weighted linear interpolation that is
easy to implement the details please see
the paper
this algorithm already allows us to
model complex bend gestures
the next algorithm is a more
sophisticated machine learning based
approach which continuously regresses
the vertex positions of the freedom Esch
again for details please see the paper
we evaluated both methods with respect
to the accuracy on a ground truth data
set both methods were capable of
accurately reconstructing most of the
shown defamations qualitatively both
methods performed equally well
however our quantitative evaluation
revealed that the machine learning based
approach yielded less error we explored
the concept of a transparent smart cover
which allows for paper-like interactions
on tablet devices the accurate
reconstruction of the defamations lets
the user physically peel or flip layers
of the user interface in this example
the user can naturally reveal specific
parts of the original photograph to see
the effect of an image filter
in this photo editing tool the user
peels off the topmost layer to access
the underlying information
here the user checks the solution of the
crossword puzzle to verify their guess
as he struggles to find the next word he
peeks at the solution by keeping the
cover lifted with the lift and drop
metaphor the user temporarily brings up
another application by bending the left
edge marks a region and drops the
content back onto the original
application the transparent foil could
also be used to let users literally peek
behind the scenes the user can see the
original footage of this video before
post-processing
this application brings back the
traditional ways of animating to digital
keyframe animation the user quickly
flips between two keyframes to sketch
the current frame after completing the
animation the user can flip through the
frames with a continuous bending motion
our sensor can also be used as a high
degree of freedom input device in this
physics playground application we
demonstrate dexterous two and a half D
interactions with virtual physics
objects
we implemented a novel game concept that
directly Maps the complex defamations of
our sensor to a magic carpet
pulling different corners or sides of
the sensor results in different
behaviors of the carpet such as changing
the direction of the flight or shooting
objects the user has to flat the sides
to gain altitude we demonstrated flex
cents a new thin film transparent
sensing surface which can reconstruct
complex defamations
without any external sensing we
presented two methods for mapping a
small number of sensors to a free
dimensional surface our fully
self-contained setup provides new
interactive possibilities